Speaker 1: As I've said many times before, if
there are no cultists, there really is no cult,
it's just a guy screaming things that don't make
sense and nobody's paying attention. And the
U.S. in the United States right now, the level
of cultish ness that has pervaded the American
right wing is getting to such a degree that even
cult isn't appropriate because cults are usually
kind of small. And unfortunately, a big part of
the modern Republican Party has been taken over
by anti empirical anti-science, in some cases
paranoid delusions that we would ordinarily say
if they replaced God with some other word
or they replaced a Republican with some
other random person, we would say, Oh, you need
help. You're in a cult. We need to get you out,
and we're going to look at some examples of that
right now. This is very interesting. We've spoken
before about this group Blacks for Trump. And
one of the questions we had about the group was,
does the group really exist because they
have almost no online presence other than
one very strange website? And Blacks for Trump
is a group that often would show up at Trump
rallies and on the stage you would see, like
over Trump's shoulder, there would be like
a strategically placed blacks for Trump person
with the shirt and everything. Often they would
be gone before the end of the speech. Well, at
Trump's rally in Delaware, Ohio, over the weekend,
right side broadcasting actually interviewed one
of these people from blacks for Trump. And it's
completely unintelligible. The guy is like really
close to the interviewer and keeps touching him.
Everything about this is bizarre. But finally,
we have actual an interview with one of these
members of blacks for Trump. Check this out.
Speaker 4: Hey, a person that comes to your aid
helps you all the time. And then when you
really want to come to your aid, suddenly
he's a racist. When he was the first one
to say the black people mattered to him.
He said it directly to me. I'm sorry about that.
Yes, he said it directly to me. And in the end, I
forget not. Jones became a symbol of Miami night,
but he's done so much for the black community, and
so he did so much for the black community, right?
Speaker 1: So there is blacks for Trump making
a point about something of just a very strange
situation. Then we move on to a woman at the Trump
rally who explains that she believes Princess
Diana and Jackie Onassis are still alive and
tries to pull the interviewer into it. It is. I
mean, listen, it's I know we always say, Well,
is it? We can't diagnose, but something
is very wrong with these folks.
Speaker 5: OK? First of all, y'all
are so cute. I love the outfit.
I would like detailed explanations on every
single shirt. Ready to go. Right. So living,
living and we know living ruin the world and you
don't take down evil by being quiet or silent,
right? So people need to understand who
they are. Do they look like them today?
No. Do you think Princess Diana is still
alive? Absolutely. 100 percent. Do you?
I deny. But maybe, maybe you have something
to that. You know that? I don't know. Well,
you know, God speaks to us, right? Right.
Speaker 1: There's ways that they can agree on.
Speaker 5: You can figure these things out. So
if people start learning ABC one two three, which
Michael Jackson talked about, how many years ago,
right? And he sang about. So when people start
understanding your mattress, they start understand
the numbers a equals one equals to C equals three.
Speaker 1: Yeah, pretty open and shut case. Now,
if you're wondering what Jamal Maitreya is going,
Maitreya is is Hebrew numerology using the the
Hebrew alphabet or, as it's known, the alphabet
where you just you're basically it's like what you
did as a kid. When you make a code and you, I'm
going to write you a note and like a is going to
be one and D will be four and that type of thing.
It's just it's Hebrew numerology, and in my
experience now, I don't want to. I'm sure there
are scholars somewhere that would be exceptions
to this. I have never in my life heard anyone
use the word Maitreya or Jew Maitreya seriously,
and they weren't completely out of their minds.
Maybe there's a counter example, but I'm certainly
not not aware of one. Here's a woman complaining
about critical race theory. Obviously, she
doesn't know what it is like a frigate.
That ship has sailed. It's not even reasonable
to expect them to know what it is at this point.
She doesn't know what it is, but it sounds like
she says her kids go to private school where,
like, they don't even teach whatever she
thinks of as critical race theory. It's
really weird, but she's very upset. Well, private
Speaker 5: school, private, private, clear fork,
Speaker 4: private. So I won't say as a parent,
what's your thoughts on what's going on or the
indoctrination of our kids with some of their
CRT and some of the other? Really radical
things are really stressful.
Speaker 5: I mean, the thing
Speaker 1: she's really stressed, I
mean, her kids go to a private school,
so it's not a problem, but it's really stressful.
Speaker 5: But they're trying to teach kids these
days just not right. You know, if it's if it
goes against God's word, then it's wrong. Mm-Hmm.
Speaker 4: Without a doubt, it's it
should be as simple as that. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, there is separation of
church and state in public schools, and so really
God's word should have no role to play whatsoever,
but very, very angry people about things which
they don't understand and they don't and they
aren't affected by. But there it is. Here's a
woman at the Trump rally who said she had 10 Trump
flags on her on her porch and the host volunteers
that it's un-American not to have flags.
Speaker 4: OK. Yeah, we've talked to them
earlier about hanging flags. Let me ask a question
in your neighborhood that you guys live in your
work. Whatever Trump's flag still flying? Oh,
absolutely. Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah. You haven't seen
my front yard. I never went down by my porch.
Speaker 1: This is literal, cultish ness. This
is you were. You were signaling your devotion.
You're signaling your devotion in some cults,
right? The way you signal your devotion is the
leader gets to have sex with whoever they want.
Right. So you look at the Jim Jones cult,
you look at the Charles Manson call. That
was a big thing. You signal your devotion by.
It was a bunch of stuff. You don't question
what the leader tells you, and you're available
to the leader for sex whenever here. The way
they signal their devotion is we never took down
our flags. We kept the Trump flags up the entire
Speaker 5: time, and we used it, if you want
to find our house, look for the house flags,
right? We have 10 flags on our porch.
Speaker 4: Yes. Yeah, I just I just did
a promo for my pillow dot com and my short
column because I said, if you have if you
don't have a flag in for your house. Hang
on a sec. You know what you're saying. I'm
un-American. Right? Put a flag in your front yard.
Speaker 1: You have to they demand compliance. You
must have the signal that you are a member of
the team. Here's one guy who says that Trump
rallies are better than Grateful Dead shows.
Speaker 4: I tell all my friends I've seen
Jerry Garcia 129 times in concert. It's
better than any Grateful Dead show,
and it smells a lot better.
Speaker 1: Go Trump. Yeah. So listen, these folks,
at least in theory, they could be your kids
orthodontist. They could be your kid's teacher.
They might be the person fixing your car or
whatever. Right. These these folks really
are everywhere. And I don't know how we
deprogram them. One last bonus clip. There
are opening prayers at these Trump events,
and the prayers are getting more and more
cult like they're praying in. Thanks for Trump
Speaker 4: for life and and we're grateful for the
living legacy of President Donald Trump. We thank
you for his willingness to continue to organize
them, to travel across our nation, delivering
the message of freedom and to remind us,
you and me that we play a critical part in saving
our nation. We thank you, God, for the clarity
of purpose you have given to President Trump.
Speaker 1: So I think you get it. Jamie Raskin,
member of Congress. He says he has started reading
about cults and consulting cult experts just for
help on how to communicate with his Republican
colleagues in the House of Representatives.
That's how bad it has gotten, and I don't know
how we teach our way out of it. I don't know how
we educate our way out of it. I really don't.
It's as depressing as I could possibly imagine.